uh welcome to the second of the day
we're very thrilled to have a nicole
with us
uh virtually
so since uh nicole is a is a true expert
in all the areas that we're covering in
the workshop
so she's really one of the leading
researchers know algorithm game theory a
lot of very important work
market design and generally on the
intersection of uh
economics uh and computer science
and uh beyond just her research
excellence nicole is really like a force
of nature in terms of
organizing thing and keeping our chaotic
community under control
and we're very we're very
pleased for all her efforts he's really
a force of nature
uh we're very very happy to have here
with us
and nicole the floor is yours thank you
i thank you so am i audible to everybody
in the
physical venue
uh
some thumbs up or something would be
nice yeah great awesome uh
i am very happy to be here i'm i'm from
microsoft research i'm based in the
boston lab and as you can see from my
virtual background a photo was taken a
short walk from my office boston has by
far better weather than berkeley
um so you should all come visit when you
get a chance
i did this work jointly with nika
hogtalab who is
at berkeley but i believe traveling at
this moment um brandon lucie
marcus mobius and divya mohan at a time
when we were all co-located in boston
pre-pandemic um
and so i'm very happy to be talking to
you today about this paper it's called
communicating with anecdotes
so what i want to talk about is a
communication game in which we have two
players there's a sender and a receiver
and the sender is going to talk to the
receiver about a state of the world the
state of the world
uh so examples that i'll sort of uh use
as motivation throughout this
introduction are politicians being
senders that want to talk to
their receivers which could be say
constituents about policy decisions that
they're making that relate to this state
of the world the state of the economy
maybe for example uh you could imagine
that there are uh the sender could be a
newspaper the new york times perhaps uh
where and the receivers then are the
readers of the newspaper and
uh the newspaper
wants to talk about some current events
or
some some newsworthy event uh that that
they've researched
um
and so the key features of the setting i
want to think about here is that there's
going to be some information asymmetry
that means that the sender knows more
than the receiver about the state of the
world so
the politicians the news reporters they
all do a lot of research and and
like
go out on listening tours and interviews
and whatnot to learn about the state of
the world and then they communicate
things about the state of the world to
the readers
who don't themselves have access to all
the information that the sender does
we also have this feature of hard
evidence so
this is going to be central to this talk
and i think one of the things that
relates it to this workshop i'm going to
assume that the way that the senders
communicate to the receivers is in the
form of data and you can think of data
in this context as being some factual
statement that is not manipulable and so
you have you can choose what to talk
about but whatever you talk about has to
be true there's no fake news
and another feature i want to model is
agency so
the reason this communication is
happening is because the receivers gets
to take some sort of action
and the sender wants to influence how
the receiver acts
and the reason is because the action of
the receiver
is payoff relevant to both the sender
and the receiver
um so a little bit more formally i mean
i'll present the formal model later in
the talk but at the moment uh
i just want to give you a slight more
formalization to help me
explain the the motivating examples uh
we have the sender the what what the
sender has access to is first of all she
has an information structure which is
going to be the signal about that she
has access to about a payoff relevant
state of the world this is like the
research she did about about what's
happening in the world and the sender
also has a strategic choice to make and
that strategic choice is what to
communicate something i'll call an
object i'll call a communication scheme
which maps
uh whatever signal she has access to
whatever signal she's received about the
state of the world to some information
that she communicates to the receiver
the receiver has also the information
structure but the receiver's information
structure is different
she only has access to beliefs about the
distribution of the signal in the state
of the world
and then she'll receive some
communication from the sender and then
take a strategic choice which in the
receiver's case is going to be an action
that for any
communication they receive to this from
the sender
uh
specifies an action choice and the
action choice is payoff relevant for
both the receiver and the sender
and the way in which uh and and then you
know the sender and receiver are going
to choose actions
strategies to maximize their utility and
expectation over the state and the
signal
um and i'll get into the exact form like
definition of the equilibrium uh in the
model section of the talk
so that like way that the action is
impacting this utility is going to be
related to
the difference between the action and
the ideal action of the agent so the
sender has an action that is um that she
would like the receiver to take uh
indicated by this blue arrow and the
receiver has an action that could be
different from the sender that she would
like to take indicated by the red arrow
and what's uh important here is that
both the sender and receiver's ideal
action is simply some shift of the state
of the world so we'll think of the state
of the world in the model as being some
real number and the
sender might prefer actions that are a
bit to the left of the state of the
world and the receiver might prefer
actions that are a bit to the right of
the state of the world
um
and so
these this is like you know the high
level of what the preferences look like
for the agents
and so now with that in mind let's think
through some motivating examples
in one example we have uh politics
politicians was one motivating example i
mentioned in the first slide so in this
example we have a sender being a
president
and the president uh she's going to tell
her
constituents some some anecdotes or some
you know some facts about the world so
what does how does she do that well she
has access to a signal about the state
of the world which is research that
she's done uh
you know by talking maybe to her
constituents or her staff is
interviewing constituents so she has a
bunch of signals uh
stories from constituents related to the
state of the world and then she goes to
her speech writers and says here's a
bunch of facts write me a speech and so
the
process by which the speech writers
sift through those facts and form them
into a speech is going to be her
communication scheme
um and maybe which the likes receiver
that she's talking to could be for
example employers and uh the
state of the world
uh is the gender wage gap so the
employers have some belief about the
gender wage gap and the employers are
going to take an action which is how
much to pay
their employees as a function of their
gender
and perhaps the president is valuing
fairness
over free markets more than the
employers do and so the president wants
to
sort of convince employers to pay women
more assuming that the gender wage gap
is
um
favors men so the president wants to
convince the employers to pay women more
the employers
want to pay a fair market wage so that
they can
uh
compete well in the marketplace and so
their preferences might not be
completely aligned uh they're just like
a little bit shifted from from the state
of the world
um
so that's an example in politics here's
an example in journalism so in
journalism again we have the sender
being
someone with more access to knowledge
about the state of the world say the new
york times for example this could be the
sender and uh the new york times gets
some signals about some state of the
world in this case let's imagine it's uh
covid
and so
they get this signals because their
journalists go out and do a lot of
research into covid
and then they have some editorial policy
that suggests what
stories they're going to report on and
what facts they're going to report in
their newspaper
and then the receiver in this case could
be the reader who has her own beliefs
about the danger of covid and the
effectiveness of wearing masks
and the action that the reader is going
to take is what fraction of time they're
going to spend wearing masks
and how much they're going to adhere to
mask wearing
recommendations and so here again you
could imagine that maybe the newspaper
values health over personal freedom more
than the readers and so the newspapers
trying to
convince the readers to wear masks more
often than they might otherwise if they
knew exactly how effective they were
and so
the
key
element of the
story i want to tell here is what we
call anecdotes anecdotes i want you to
think of this as something immutable
that you can tell me about
but you so you can tell you can choose
whether to tell me about this immutable
thing
um but you can't change it right and so
this could be like the new york times
interviews a bunch of people and some in
some city about
uh their experiences with covid they
can't make up a story from these people
they can just print a story that they
hear but they don't have to print every
story they hear
um
so more formally as the signal that i've
mentioned as the sender has access to a
signal i want to think of the signal as
being a set of samples or anecdotes that
are drawn from a distribution
that's
correlated with the state of the world
and throughout this talk i'm going to
additionally assume that the sender has
access to a signal that
is equal to the state of the world but
this so the sender actually even knows
exactly what the state of the world is
um but can't communicate that because
it's not one of these anecdotes that she
has access to
um
so like i might know precisely how
effective mask wearing is because i'm a
scientist and i've spent a career
building up
models and intuitions and and like
you know
theories about this but i can't just
tell you that i have to convince you by
sending you facts
um this foresight assumption is uh we we
can do away with it in the paper this is
mostly for convenience and cleanliness
of the
of the notation in the context of this
talk um
so here's some examples
from of of anecdotes from those two
uh settings i i mentioned of politicians
and journalism here's an actual uh quote
from a stump speech of clinton
um
and this highlighted section here is not
actually my highlighting i pulled this
off of a website off of npr
uh
and what the the npr story was about how
clinton
talks a lot in anecdotes in her thump
speeches and she tells lots of anecdotes
and that this is the way that she tries
to convince voters of the uh
of the issues that she thinks are
important to the country and so here's
an example off of that npr website of a
stump speech of hers where she's telling
this anecdote about the gender wage gap
where she met two
people with the same job a man and a
woman and they were making different
amounts of money for the exact same job
here's an example from journalism this
is actually the
upfront cover of the new york times from
may 24th 2020
probably many of you remember this it
was it was pretty impactful uh it's
uh listing a hundred
a thousand people that died of covid
and the headline you could think of this
as an anecdote that
u.s deaths near a hundred thousand
um
so these are
some examples of where we see anecdotes
in the world around us
and uh so now i want to think about
what is
what happens in our world because we
communicate in anecdotes like what can
we conclude about the world if we assume
that communication happens in anecdotes
and for the purposes of this talk i'm
going to assume that you can communicate
only a single anecdote but you have may
have access as a sender to many
anecdotes and so the
point here is that you get to
strategically select which anecdotes to
communicate
and then we're going to ask questions
about uh what happens as a result of
this we'll ask
what's
anecdote ends up being communicated what
anecdote does the sender choose and what
we'll see is that um
the sender is going to
in general
pick a biased anecdote uh
and the reason that she'll be doing this
is because she wants to convince the
receiver that the state is closer to her
ideal point so that the receiver's
action becomes closer to her ideal point
uh but
she also because her ideal point depends
on the state of the world itself it's a
shift from the state of the world she
also has some incentive for accuracy um
and so she will try and then there's
this tension now between bias and
accuracy she has some incentive to try
and give the receiver
uh accurate information about the state
of the world
the other thing we're going to look at
is let's think about some parallel
worlds
where there's you know
many different senders and in in you
know one universe i can listen to a
sender that's pretty similar to me in
another universe i can listen to a
sender that's maybe not very similar to
me in terms of her preferences but has a
lot more experience and a lot more data
to pull from and so what sorts of worlds
would i rather live in as a receiver
where do i get the most utility and what
we'll see is that there is some tendency
towards polarization so senders
with similar ideal points are going to
give me anecdotes as a receiver that
have less bias which will make me
happier and so i if all
holding everything else equal i'd rather
talk to people that are more similar
than me to me
uh not out of any sort of inherent
bias on myself or
but simply because i get more
information out of those people
now you could say well maybe the people
who are experts are not very similar to
you
and um
indeed if a sender has
many many anecdotes you could think of
that as being some measure of the
expertise of the sender then
even if they're sending me biased
anecdotes it could be that that anecdote
gives me more information than a less
biased one from a less informed receiver
but it could also go the other way
around and so we'll see an example of
that later in the talk
um but you know at this point you can
just think that we'll see through this
model that senders uh
receivers have a tendency to to polarize
who they listen to and they have a
tendency to seek out experts
um so before i get into the model i want
to relate this a little bit to
the literature and economics that deals
with these sorts of communication games
the one probably most related to our
paper is this seminal work of crawford
and sobel on cheap talk
uh and so
this is a
model where the sender can't commit to
her communication scheme uh so they're
playing some sort of nash equilibrium
style game
and uh what they see is that
uh
it's actually a very interesting paper i
encourage you all to read it they they
see that the language in which people
choose to communicate
has different degrees of granularity and
the more fine-grained languages are an
equilibrium when the preferences are
more in line and therefore we can
communicate more effectively when our
preferences are more aligned and we'll
see similar kind of intuition in our in
our model as well
the other paper um
that we relate to is the literature and
persuasion
and this is more of a stackleberg style
game so the sender is able to commit to
a particular communication scheme say
like a newspaper with a long-standing
tradition has a particular editorial
policies
uh about what they print what types of
things they print
um so if if they have access to this
type of commitment then we're in a more
of a persuasion style world
and or
this prior literature shows a
characterization of the optimal scheme
um
which includes some some pooling and and
they sort of say when you have this kind
of pooling
and so
i probably won't talk much about this
our scheme
with the persuasion
uh interpretation in this talk given
that i only have an hour but uh you can
look into the paper for that
that link
the other sort of strand of literature
we relate to is the literature on
selection or voluntary disclosure so
here
uh
there's
a sender with a bunch of facts and they
can select a subset of those facts to
communicate just like in our game
and the sort of most of the literature
here is thinking about a sender being a
seller of some good and the facts that
the seller can communicate are related
to the quality of the good and so the
seller no matter what the state of the
world is no matter what the true quality
is the seller wants to convince the
buyer that it's that the good is really
high quality because then they'll get a
better price
and so the classic work in this little
area of grossman heart
milgram and roberts shows that you get
full unraveling so
the seller because any news that they
don't reveal is perceived as bad news
they'll end up telling you everything
about their product
um and then there's some more recent
literature looking at uh settings in
which this type of result breaks down
um our game is a bit different from
these because the
uh as i mentioned the
sender in our game has some uh
preference that
the receiver has an accurate belief
about the state of the world
um okay so with that background i'll
introduce the model
i have as i've said two players in my
game a sender and a receiver
the uh
state of the world so nature is going to
choose a state of the world theta and
this state of the world i'm going to
assume is drawn from a diffuse prior
that is it's equally likely to be
anywhere
the preferences of the agents are
ideal shifts
from this state of the world so
the preference of the sender is going to
be
theta plus ms some
that would be the sender's ideal action
for the receiver to take and the
preference of the receiver would be
theta plus mr
and
the
sender also has access to anecdotes
these anecdotes are going to be drawn
from some distribution
that's uh parameterized by the state of
the world so for example you could just
in your talk in this talk have in your
mind that this distribution is say
gaussian with mean theta and variance
one and there will be n anecdotes drawn
from this distribution
so that's the the setting now what's the
information structure of my game i'm
going to have the ideal shifts of the
sender and receiver be comment knowledge
the uh both the sender and receiver are
also going to know the number of
anecdotes accessible to the sender n as
well as the class of priors from which
they're drawn so gaussian say
and then the sender only is going to
have additional information which is for
the purposes of the talk the state of
the world theta
and the instantiation of these n
anecdotes so the realizations of these n
anecdotes x1 to xn
the strategies are as follows the sender
is going to select a communication
scheme which you can think about as a
mapping from the set of
anecdotes to a chosen one
such that the chosen anecdote is
is is
one that was realized so for any vector
of anecdotes x i'm going to pick some
index i and communicate that index x i
to the receiver
the receiver's
strategy is going to be an action rule
which is going to be for anything that
i've been told by the sender
what action am i going to take and we
think of all of this as living on the
real number line
so that it's simply a function mapping
the received
anecdote to an action
and the timing of the game is going to
be as follows you can uh think of nature
first drawing the state of the world
from the diffuse prior and then these
anecdotes from the distribution
uh that's parametrized by theta
then the sender is going to select a
communication scheme and pull out
whichever anecdote she chooses to send
to the receiver
that's going to get communicated to the
receiver the receiver is going to look
at the anecdote that they received pick
an action that they're going to take
based on their action rule
and then take that chosen action
can i ask a question sure so
is it correct that you draw an entire
vector x and then you pick one scalar
value and that is your anecdote yes
exactly okay thank you
um
and then by you i guess nature draws
this vector x
or you could think yeah you know it's
drawn from that distribution so you
don't have you you can't
uh influence which x's get realized but
you can influence which x you send
okay uh so this is the timing of the
game and what are the payoffs
and
these payoffs are by the way exactly the
ones from the
uh
example section in in crawford sobel
they can generalize their model a bit
but this is the what they work with
primarily uh it's going to be the mean
squared distance between the
ideal points and the action for each
player so the sender's utility is
or like the sender's loss is going to be
the uh distance between the action that
the receiver took
and her ideal point
and the receiver's loss is the distance
between the action that she took and
her own ideal point
okay
and so now you can see that this uh
state of the world theta is showing up
in the utility function and if there's a
lot of variance over theta
it's going to induce variance in the
receiver's action which is going to harm
the sender's utility so you can start to
see this coming into the model here
um
okay so those are the payoffs what's the
solution concept i'm interested in uh
i'm going to be working with a perfect
bayesian equilibrium i
the equilibrium i'm going to
characterize and focus on is also a nash
equilibrium and and i think that's a
little bit more familiar of a concept to
this audience so if you don't know what
a pb is
don't worry about it just think of it as
a nash equilibrium um so this is going
to be an equilibrium profile
uh
of strategies a communication scheme pi
s for the sender and an action rule ar
for the receiver such that each one is
the best response to the other
there's also in the paper a discussion
of stackelberg equilibria and
um
which which is sort of the persuasion
style set of results but i won't have
time to go over that today
so
let's see if we can characterize i mean
i mean my goal here is to characterize
this nash equilibrium and try to
understand
what uh
what anecdotes are communicated in the
nash equilibrium and then
derive from that some comparative
statics but in order to get there first
i'm going to characterize for you the
best response
of the sender and receiver so what do
best responses of senders and receivers
look like
and what we'll see is that the sender so
this is an informal statement of what
i'm going to show you now which is that
when you're communicating with anecdotes
um there's going to be yeah could i ask
a question um
i'm wondering in the setup that you
described seems very sequential so i
can't even make sense of nash in the
setting like could you give an intuition
of how would that work because there's
really an order in the story that you
told us there needs to be like a
communication that happens so that the
receiver responds
so how can you understand the national
situation
yeah so the
you can think about the
uh
the sender is going to
choose
so the receiver is going to choose an
action that is a
uh maximizing their utility given their
belief so this expectation here is over
the beliefs of the receiver
um so actually so this this is why i
didn't
this is why i say it's really a pbe the
the perfect bayesian equilibrium is
characterized by an equilibrium profile
and the beliefs of the receiver
and so the
uh receiver
has to be taking a best response in
expectation over her beliefs
um about the state of the world which
are influenced by the
communication she received as well as
the uh
uh distribution from which the anecdotes
are drawn right um and she has to be
maximizing this expectation
with respect to those beliefs
you can
now you you might be a little bit
bothered by the fact that i'm asking her
to pick an action rule
and that is a function instead of a
specific action
but um you know you can ask her to solve
this problem for any anecdote she might
receive and then that defines this
function
uh and simultaneously or i guess
sequentially if you prefer um
before she does that the receiver the
sender is picking this best response to
whatever action role the the receiver is
taking
if you prefer you can also think about
them as picking these functions pi and a
up front but i just found in my last
talk that that bothered people because
like up front i mean before nature
chooses the anecdotes that would be
maybe more comfortable if you want to
think about nash equilibria but
yeah that's equivalent okay cool thank
you
just curious so for the receiver to uh
update the belief
do they need to know the set of
available anecdotes
uh yeah so the
entire real number line is the set of
available anecdotes oh but they don't
know what are the ones that the sender
has no
no okay
thank you
so if yeah if they knew
like
the
set uh so this is sort of the unraveling
that happens in um grossman
hart milgram robert's paper line of
papers but hey i guess i won't get into
that in the interest of time but if
you're interested in that sort of
you you there you often see like
equilibrium of the form i kind of know
what type of information you had access
to so if you didn't tell me about the
battery life of the cell phone i'm going
to assume it's pretty bad
but that kind of thing doesn't happen
here
um
so
sorry uh
uh so the question is like is pi s which
is a strategy of the sender
is that like a
just mapping from a vector to an index
of the vector or can the sender
manipulate his report
it's a mapping from the vector to an
element of the vector
uh and the sender cannot so the receiver
doesn't know which like whether it was
the
like lowest anecdote or the the highest
anecdote
necessarily right
um
so it's not it's not like i told you
this is the second element of my vector
is blah
rather it's an it's a mapping from a
vector to
an element of the vector and i cannot
manipulate it so i have access only to
these n
[Music]
points
right i only have access to these
endpoints the green dots on the slide
and what i'm allowed to do as the sender
is from this collection this set of
points or the specter of points i can
pick one of them and tell you about it
okay so what we're going to see is that
the sender is the the types of
communication schemes that senders will
use in the equilibrium we characterize
is they're going to shift the state to
some
point in on the real number line so
they're going to shift it to the left in
the
settings that i've been drawing on the
slides and then they're going to find
the anecdote that's closest to that
shifted state and report that one
and what the receiver is going to do is
that well for any such scheme there's
some bias that the receiver can
calculate so the receiver knows the
expected bias of the sender scheme and
she's going to simply try to de-bias
the reported anecdote by shifting it
back to the right
and then she'll use that as an unbiased
estimator of the state of the world and
take the optimal action with with that
posterior
so that's what going to be what the
communication looks like
let's
actually write it down
the action rule i'm going to define a
class of action rules that correspond to
what i just described informally
which is
which we call translations so we say an
action rule is a translation
if for any anecdote i receive
the action i take
if that anecdote gets shifted by delta
is equal to the shifted action plus
delta
so
i tell you
you know i tell you something you take
an action if i tell you something
slightly to the right your action is
going to move by that same amount to the
right
this is a translation
and uh
one thing to note is that if an action
rule is a translation then there's some
constant shift sigma such that
the action
you know you can write that the action
rule a of x is x plus sigma and this is
that informal interpretation i was
giving you in the previous slide you can
think of this as the receiver is simply
de-biasing the anecdote by
the
their posterior belief about the bias of
the scheme
communication schemes the class of
communication schemes that we'll observe
in our equilibrium characterization
are
translation invariant
and what that means is that
the
if every thing that there is that the
sender sees gets shifted by delta
then what she chooses to send is also
shifted by delta so if if we take the
world we make a copy of it where the
state of the world is to the right by
delta and all the anecdotes move to the
right by delta then what she chooses to
send is also move to the right by delta
this means that she's not saying things
like this is the anecdote closest to
zero right because this absolute number
zero has no meaning in this world
um
and so this is going to uh
sort of i think be a natural class of
schemes given that we have this diffuse
prior over the state it's also
uh
without loss of general like the
equilibrium i'm describing is an
equilibrium among the class of all
action rules and
uh communication schemes so it's not a
restriction it's just
something that falls out of our of our
model
um
so just to make sure we've understood
what a translation and variant
communication scheme is here's some
examples the minimum anecdote is one
translation invariant communication
scheme
uh
the anecdote closest to the state would
be another one
i guess that's not in this picture
actually the anecdote closest to the
state but um yeah uh
the anecdote closest to some shift of
the state which is going to be the uh
the schemes that are going to be in our
equilibrium those are also translation
invariant and so let me
define now
this type of scheme we're going to call
it a targeting scheme a targeting scheme
of the sender is going to take the state
of the world theta shift it by some
offset tau and then send the anecdote
that's closest to theta plus tau
so
uh another
definition that will be useful for
thinking about
uh the best responses of the agents is
the bias of a communication scheme and
this is it's natural to think we should
worry about the bias because you know
the receiver wants to understand what
theta is so she can pick her
action equal to her ideal point so she's
going to try to think about the bias
that the sender
um
has and and debias whatever
communication the sender sends and this
is i think also very natural to us when
we think about these examples of like
the new york times we all know it's
a slightly to the left newspaper so we
read it with a grain of salt what do we
mean by that we mean we think about the
fact that what they've the facts we
don't i think most of us doubt the facts
of the that the new york times is
reporting but we think about
uh the
the
that the facts that they report might be
selected to be a little bit on the left
and and then update our beliefs
accordingly
uh so
here's uh just an example of what the
bias is to make this
pictorially apparent and it's going to
become important later let's look at
these types of communication schemes
i've told you will be important which
are these targeting schemes
then the bias of the targeting scheme
is going to be
a little bit to the right so i have this
i've told you to imagine in your head
gaussian distribution uh so i guess this
isn't drawn very much to look like a
gaussian but um you imagine that that
there's this gaussian distribution
centered at theta it means that there's
more mass to the right of the target
than the left because
uh
i shifted off to the left and so
uh the bias of my scheme i'm more likely
to find an anecdote on the right and so
the bias of the scheme is going to be
something
between tau and theta like drawn in the
slide
um
and one thing that will become important
here is this gap between
this blue arrow and the
star so there's a gap between the offset
of the targeting scheme and its bias
so
um
we're now ready we have the the
definitions in place of the targeting
uh
scheme that the
action rules that are translations the
communication schemes that are
translation and variant and the bias of
a communication scheme those are the
ingredients we need to
write down the best response of the
receiver and so the lemma is that the
best response of the receiver
to a translation invariant communication
scheme with some particular bias beta is
going to be a translation with shift mr
minus beta
and this is quite easy to see um
you can just write down the
uh
the
utility of the
receiver notice that because i've chosen
it to be mean square distance it's going
to be maximized when the action is equal
to
the
uh
shift that i claimed
and so
i won't get into the details of this but
i think this is pretty
pretty apparent am i supposed to end it
at three
or my time at noon
yes sir at noon our time i guess yes
so this is i'm gonna have to speed up a
little bit this is the uh
uh
communicate you can look at this dilemma
pictorially the sender picks an anecdote
to communicate the receiver perceives
some bias of this communication scheme
and so shifts that anecdote to the right
by that bias and then
makes an additional shift to the right
by her offset mr
her shift mr and that's the action she
takes
uh the sender's best response can be
also defined here
um
and so let's think let's suppose now
that the receiver is
doing an action of this translation
shape this translation form that i just
showed you
what would the receiver do the sender do
if she knew the receiver was doing that
and what she would do is to
pick a
communication scheme so pick an anecdote
um
that is translation invariant and
now the sender of course knows the set
of anecdotes and in our talk at least
the state of the world theta and so
she's trying to do this she's trying to
maximize her utility point wise and
point why she can do this by picking
a anecdote that's um
ideally she would love to pick an
anecdote that equals the state of the
world plus some
uh
target that's
uh chosen to make the
receiver
act as she would like the receiver to
act but she can't pick
just an arbitrary real number to send
we've restricted her to pick anecdotes
and so
uh what she has to do is pick the
anecdote that's closest to her i the one
that what she would want to say so if
she could say anything she would say
theta plus ms minus sigma but since she
can only say anecdotes she's going to
pick the anecdote that's closest to that
and so we call this a communication
scheme
this communication scheme a targeting
scheme with offset tau
and so now we know that the
receiver's best response the sender's
best response is a targeting scheme with
offset ms minus sigma where sigma is the
shift that the receiver is going to
apply to the communication she receives
um
so
that's
now given us enough information to
actually write down a fixed point
equation that characterizes our
equilibrium
and i think it's useful to
also go through this
exercise of trying to understand
what's pulling the sender in different
directions i'm going to skip this in the
interest of time this derivation but you
can you can equivalently characterize
the sender's best response by thinking
about
um
sort of rewriting this her utility to
illuminate the forces that are
influencing her in one direction or
another that she wants to
try and
convince persuade the receiver
at the same time as give the receiver
some degree of accurate information
so we will skip this
uh and with the best response lemmas in
hand let's write down what the nash
equilibrium is that's actually going to
be quite easy
we'll be able to write down that the
equilibrium scheme is biased
we'll be able to see what the bias looks
like and we'll be able to note that the
bias of the scheme grows
as the
like and this is the comparative statics
part that i'm quite interested in the
bias of the screen scheme grows as the
difference in ideal points so the sort
of preference misalignment between the
sender and receiver grows
and also the bias of the scheme grows as
the number of anecdotes available to the
sender grows
so let's see how that works out
um
first
remember i'm going to define something
we've already seen this definition of
bias but i want to
make it apparent what the uh
what's going to end up being important
here is this gap between the target tau
so this blue arrow and the bias beta so
this yellow star
the gap between the offset tau and
the
bias
beta
one thing to notice about this is that
it grows as the target diverges from the
state
so if we have a target that's zero that
is my scheme is let's send the most
representative anecdote the anecdote
closest to the state of the world then
the bias of that scheme is clearly zero
right because we have this gaussian
distribution in our heads that's
centered at theta so this this scheme
has no bias
but as we start to try and find
anecdotes that are
further and further to the left
the bias of the scheme is going to
grow as the target moves further and
further to the left
but furthermore the gap between the bias
and the
offset grows as the target moves further
and further left and that's because the
distribution the tails get thinner and
thinner and so the anecdotes that i'm
finding to send to you
are not very close to my target as i go
far out in the tail
does that make sense
so
that turns out to be the key quantity
that characterizes the equilibria
and another thing to notice which will
be important for the comparative statics
is that the rate at which this gap grows
the gap between the blue arrow and the
yellow star is a function of the number
of anecdotes as well because as i have
more and more anecdotes
they'll
they'll be
more things closer to me even when i'm
out in the tail and so the gap doesn't
grow as rapidly as when i have few
anecdotes
um and so now
this gap this tau minus beta
is
the key thing that characterizes the
nash equilibrium this this formula that
i've written on the slide falls directly
out of the
best response characterizations that we
saw in the previous section of the talk
and so what what it says is that this
gap that we discussed on the previous
slide must equal the preference
misalignment in any equilibrium
um and
of course we also have to argue that the
equilibrium exists this is this is of
some sort of fixed point equation so we
have to argue that this that there is a
solution and
uh that's uh not too hard first the
characterization follows from the best
response dynamics the solution uh
the existence follows from some simple
arguments about the monotonicity of this
gap as as the target diverges from the
state
but uh what i wanted to focus on
um
is that this model helps us understand
some
comparative statics that might shed
light onto
how
the world operates uh so this this is
the theorem from the previous slide the
characterization of equilibrium
and
there's
several observations two observations we
can make looking at this first let's
imagine that the number of anecdotes is
fixed and consider the receiver
uh
in a world with different senders
different universes of the have
different senders right so every sender
has three anecdotes but
um
some senders have a ideal shift ms
that's pretty close to mr and other
senders might have an ideal shift that's
farther from mr
and
because this gap between the
target and the bias that is the
left-hand side of the
characterization theorem
grows as the
target
moves further left
that means that the
sender that's
less aligned with the receiver is going
to have a more extreme target
right so if there's some gap ms minus mr
there's going to be some solution to
this equation and if ms minus mr is
larger the target of the sender is going
to shift even further left
so that's one observation
the other observation that we can read
directly from this equation is that if
we fix this preference misalignment that
is we fix the right hand side of this
equality
then the uh but we let the number of
anecdotes in the world grow
then the offset is going to grow as the
number of anecdotes grows so when we
have just two anecdotes
i might
uh
have to go
not so far out in the tail to find a
particular gap in expectation between
the target tau and the bias
beta but as the number of anecdotes gets
very large because there's going to be
many anecdotes close to me even when i'm
out in the tail i have to go much
farther out in the tail to get that
exact same difference that exact same
gap
um
so
these two comparative statics give us
some
very interesting implications
first is uh
this observation that extreme anecdotes
so the anecdotes that are far out in the
tail are noisy and so there's going to
be some sort of accuracy loss or
signaling loss due to the fact that
these anecdotes are noisy
for equal experience levels that is if
two senders have the same number of
anecdotes then the first comparative
static we saw
says that
the better aligned our preferences are
the less far out in the tail that the
sender has to go right and so since the
receiver wants accuracy the receiver is
going to communicate with a sender who
has similar preferences because that's
more informative
the other
implication which is maybe a little bit
more surprising is that um there could
be differing experience levels right so
this is the second comparative static
we're focusing on now there might be two
senders that have different numbers of
anecdotes
the one you could think of this as being
experience
in that the the sender that has access
to more anecdotes is more of an expert
and
you can think about
distributions of the anecdotes such that
this receiver prefers to communicate
with a
less experienced sender who has more
similar preferences so i might
you know as a listener in the world seek
out uh people who are like me as opposed
to experts because i get more accurate
information from the people who are like
me
and so an example that that demonstrates
this is let's suppose sender one is an
expert that is they have many anecdotes
but their
ideal shift is far from the receivers
whereas sender two has few anecdotes but
an equal ideal shift
since the ideal shifts are equal in the
second case the sender is going to send
the most representative anecdote and
there's only a few anecdotes so that
most repre you know every anecdote for
sender 2 is pretty noisy but they're all
centered around the mean of the
distribution where there's a lot of mass
and so it might be less noisy than
extreme anecdotes
if the distribution is heavy-tailed
enough
so
let me wrap up and then i can take a few
questions
we talked about a model of communication
with anecdotes and that inherently is
going to result in information loss
because i can't tell you exactly the
state of the world i can only tell you
about stories that were drawn
from a distribution that's um correlated
with the state of the world
uh and this kind of information s loss
uh this is the part i didn't cover but
like if the sender could commit she's
going to want to send representative
anecdotes because the persuasion bias
disappears when she's able to commit to
her communication scheme
um but this uh
this
information law still exists because of
the discreteness of what i can say
um
and with commitment which is what we saw
for most of this talk the sender is
going to pick the
uh
sorry what we didn't see in this talking
i just said that the sender picks the
most representative anecdote without
commitment which is what we saw in this
talk the sender is going to pick biased
anecdotes and we can say things about
how biased so fixing the number of
anecdotes the bias that the sender of
what the sender says
is going to grow with the difference in
the ideal shifts that preference
misalignment between her and the
receiver
and if we fix that preference
misalignment then the bias
of what the sender says is going to grow
as the number of anecdotes grows
and this means that for some uh
distributions of anecdotes the receiver
prefers to communicate with less
informed senders
um and that is sort of a drive towards
polarization in society uh that i think
is somewhat novel
and so the open question here that i i'm
interested in is like throughout this
entire paper we are focusing on a
setting with one sender and one receiver
i mean we compare their uh
the utility profiles in different in
different setups but we always have this
the receiver doesn't have any choice
about who to listen to
but you could imagine a population of
people maybe initially you could imagine
you have a population of senders and a
population of receivers
and uh you could ask about what sorts of
uh
you know clusters form in this world but
even more interesting for me would be if
you have
everybody could be both a sender and a
receiver and
then you could track how anecdotes
travel through the communication network
and so
you have you could say like what people
eventually hear this story
and look at that information flow and
the resulting
beliefs and actions in the society with
many agents who both
send and receive
so with that i'll wrap up and take any
questions
can you get any calling for your talk
hi um
i have a question on the thing that you
said but i have also other questions um
so on the last thing that you said were
so you could consider a model where you
had agents that can both send and
receive information because you kind of
see that as a market i'm guessing
because it's really like essentially
people are exchanging things and what
you're really like looking for i guess
is like how
i guess prices in that market change is
have you ever thought of something like
that
oh that's an interesting interpretation
i um
i guess here the price
is my
uh attention or
because i'm guessing they're exchanging
some ideas so it's like you know yeah
certain ideas
and you could compute that equilibria
like like equilibrium prices and see
actually what ideas end up being
important or not
i'm having a little bit of trouble
imagining what the price of an idea
would be in this model i mean there's no
money obviously but i think you're on to
something which is maybe
there's
some other
element of the model i can associate
with a with a
bit of information maybe like it's
how how much it spreads or its
centrality and in the final network or
something and associate that with the
price because i'm thinking something
like maybe like an air to burn market
where you don't actually have you know
money and it's kind of just like
like the
worth of like each of the goods like
kind of like based on to a numeric good
and there it really feels like it's like
what is the relative importance of each
idea with respect to each other so it's
like a higher price with the note that
you know it's an idea that's more
listened to by people than others but i
don't know it says yeah it's interesting
i mean the thing here is like i don't
get to pick what i buy from you on like
an arrow to bro right like you get to
pick what to tell me
so
and you might choose to tell me
something different than you choose to
tell like georgios i see what you're
saying okay
um the other question i have is um in
this
i really loved your natural equilibrium
theorem um
just the implications of it are super
cool like for polarization you know like
as you get more polarization i guess
things are going to get worse but i was
wondering if you considered feedback
loops into this so you know as you're
getting uh more bias you know your ideal
state of the world also switches and so
that might lead to different changes so
have you considered that and also what
are some have you ever thought of
interventions for this
and
like ways to actually get get rid of
these uh maybe feedback loops or these
negative like polarization effect
effects
yeah so i skipped a part where you could
kind of see this feedback loop i was
gonna um explain how
unraveling could happen if we didn't
care about the
uh state of the world like if that
if if i just wanted you to no matter
what the state of the world is i want
your action to be at minus infinity
then this feedback loop just like
amplifies and amplifies and we get the
most biased thing in the world
um
but when we have so so there's this
attenuate natural attenuation to that
kind of feedback loop there's another
kind of feedback loop that you
might have been worried about which is
like
a repeated game so i i wasn't sure which
kind of thing you meant but that you
could also imagine
so this first kind of feedback loop is
just sort of happening in our heads like
i'm thinking about what's my best
response to you given that you're best
responding to me given that i'm best
responding to you and so on and so on
and that unravels
uh what i want to do in a single shot
game but you could also ask about a
repeated game and i guess
um
the sort of
extreme assumption you could make in a
repeated game is that this
seller the sender has uh has a
reputation and so that can kind of be
like commitment
and so there you could imagine in the
extreme case i am able to commit to what
i'm going to do forevermore um
and that
i don't
like i but i don't know how to do
intermediate things
uh where like we're gonna play this for
10 times right
so that that could be an interesting
kind of thing to look at
and another reason i like that direction
by the way is i didn't discuss this
motivation for this but
uh one thing i like to think about is
that the sender is myself today and the
receiver is myself a year from now and
like i had an experience today i gave a
talk at simon's and i need to think
about what am i going to remember from
this talk right and i can't remember
like
the like every detail i can only store
one one memory in my head my memory was
that like you asked me this question
right and then
a year from today i'm gonna
have access that self that receiver is
gonna have access to that
fact only
um yeah
um i'm also curious to uh i mean you
didn't go over them uh but how do the
results compare between the nash and the
stackelberg setting
um like how does sequentiality affect
actually the outcome of the prediction
yeah so the
stackelberg settings pretty cool
math like technically i think what i
showed you today was very easy
technically the stackelberg one um
it's really interesting because if you
don't have this foresight about the
state of the world so let's suppose that
the sender doesn't know the state of the
world either they just can form a
posterior over it
then their posterior is correlated with
the anecdotes right
and so it gets very complicated to think
about
what the sender wants to send when her
sorry this did i say receiver i meant
center the sender sees these anecdotes
she doesn't know the state of the world
she just has a posterior over the state
of the world based on the anecdotes she
sees and now
her posterior and the anecdotes are
themselves correlated and so this
introduces a lot of complications into
the equilibrium characterization when
she wants to try and commit to what
she's going to say
and
as a result we can only prove things
asymptotically and asymptotically as the
number of anecdotes goes grows
we can show that the optimal scheme we
can drive a wedge between the scheme
that sends the anecdote closest to the
posterior and any other scheme so ask
the like in brief the answer to your
question is asymptotically the sender
will want to send the anecdote closest
to her posterior
okay
and i promise last question um the for
your utility functions um you have this
square term there and i'm kind of
curious to know if that actually affects
by what which amount you're gonna get a
bias
uh like maybe that's gonna maybe it
might induce more polaris like a more
polarized um
like outcome or what do you think like
if you change your utility functions
would you get different like if you had
a difference i guess um
distance metric rather than yeah
this concavity like yeah it's going to
be important definitely i
would love to prove this result for more
general utility functions what i'm using
a lot is that the uh
the
only thing that we need to worry about
is the unbiased s like the the posterior
mean
and when i move away from this quadratic
form
uh you might care about
moments other than the mean so this is
the technical barrier
um
i haven't thought about it much more
deeply than that
awesome thank you very much
hi uh thank you for your talk
i had a question about have you have you
thought about maybe applying these ideas
to a real data set like i was thinking i
think it's probably hard but maybe you
could see the anecdotes as certain
items in the newspapers or something and
then you could have
multiple
receivers and maybe looking into
how quickly people can change their
opinions based on the type of newspaper
that they read
i don't know yeah i haven't thought
about trying to take this to data but i
guess it does make some
pretty
testable predictions like
about
if if we know that say
in some countries with a
um i don't know
sort of
government controlled media maybe you
could
make form estimates of what this
difference preference misalignment
between the sender and receiver is in
various countries and try to see if the
state-controlled media
sends more and more extreme things when
the citizens are less supportive of the
regime for example
so that would be a prediction of this
model
it's it's pretty hard i think because
there's so many
like you know
experimental economists would be like
but that's
there's so many other explanations you
could have had
sure what it's caused that
okay thank you
yes
oh hi nicola thanks for the nice talk
you see a little bit more about your
final open question about have multiple
agents
so like i was thinking about the example
we provide like the newspaper and the
mask bearing
so if i'm a receiver
i read some newspapers i consider that
what action can i take like how much
time i wear the mask but
my own decision on my my own action
seems less
uh sensitive to the to the
utility it's only like a group of agents
move together they're going to shift the
utility of the center
yeah so
um
you i think maybe the first step towards
a society with many agents is one sender
and many receivers and then the sender
is going to look at the distribution of
ideal points of the receivers
and assuming that it's a sort of
broadcast mechanisms the sender has to
say the same thing to all the receivers
you could ask
what's a sender facing a
distribution of mr is going to say i
think that all of this theory will go
through if you replace
what i was calling mr with the mean mr
in that setting
um
now
the next step might be
okay so now we we understand how
ascender talks to a distribution of
receivers but what if there are
multiple senders how would they talk
like
then there's then then you have to sort
of wonder does the
sender
kind of
compete with the other senders so like
does the new york times compete with the
wall street journal and try to steal
readership or is it simply that like
i just care about the like i don't i
don't really care about my as a sender
my utility isn't related to my
readership but rather to the
mask wearing in the population overall
and
i think that would be the first intro
like i don't know how to solve that
problem that would be my first
interesting question is like let's say
there's the new york times in the wall
street journal
they have slightly different preferences
over mask wearing and there's a
population of readers and for any
editorial policy or communication scheme
of the newspapers there's going to be
some like readers are going to listen to
one versus the other and
then there's going to be some resulting
action in the entire population so like
should the new york times move to the
right to get more readers so that they
wear masks more but then they they won't
be able to convince them as well right
like
you just think thanks
uh very nice talk i have a sort of kind
of like technical question
so it seems to me that there's this uh
you know there may be zero measure set
of games where
uh the center may have uh two different
best responses so let's say i have the
thing that i would ideally like to
communicate but have exactly like two
symmetric anecdotes left and right
and in this case uh you know
anything like probably any probably
distribution over them
somehow is probably a meaningful action
for me is this something that uh which
could probably complicate
the problem from the receiver end
i mean i guess you can you can
you can deal away with a small let's say
regularity assumptions say this is never
seen and i'm okay with that
but uh i just wondering is it something
that that that you thought about or
yeah this is a very good question i
i didn't think about that specific
setup because as you said i'm not that
concerned with sets of measure zero i
do have a suspicion that this is
generically unique equilibrium i did not
claim that in this talk because i can't
prove it but
it's
i'm buying it i'm buying it okay
thank you thank you nicole very
interesting talk and let's all thank
nicole again